I think that there's several reasons to
own fossils the science is only one of
them I've made millions and dollars in
the dinosaur business the thrill
discovery doesn't get old it's almost
like an addiction there is a fight going
on in the world of dinosaur fossils the
market for these prehistoric treasures
is booming but increasingly wealthy
individuals are buying up the best
specimens and that has paleontologists
worried a rare baby t-rex fossil is for
sale on eBay some scientists and other
critics are calling the listing a
disgrace last year a baby t-rex fossil
was listed on eBay for 2.95 million
dollars the sale outraged many
paleontologists according to a letter
from the Society of vertebrate
paleontology if the fossil was sold to a
private buyer it would effectively be
lost to science since private buyers are
under no obligation to share their
fossils with researchers the scientific
community is trying to hurt us they want
to discourage anyone from making money
selling fossils I tell you what I've
been charmed had a charmed life and it's
all because I picked fights and I'm
picking fights now and I'm doing it in a
different way I'm going after scientific
community they need to open up allen
dietrich is the commercial fossil hunter
selling the baby t-rex
this is son of Samson the smallest
trance or Shrek's dinosaur in the world
son of Samson was found in 2013
near Jordan Montana Dietrich's t-rex is
a scientifically significant find which
is why he had hope to sell it to the
American Museum of Natural History it's
an important specimen he has made a big
effort to try to get it into a public
institution we were interested in it for
instance but it just didn't work out
if purely comes down to an issue of
price Dietrich told the Wall Street
Journal that he offered to sell the
dinosaur to the American Museum of
Natural History for 1 million dollars
which was about two million less than
the asking price usually like in the art
market well it's been on the market for
a long time it's either not that good or
they're asking too much money so it gets
kind of stale but Dietrich has been in
the fossil business for decades and he's
confident that he'll find a buyer you
know if you can't wait
you'll spend too much or you won't make
enough money this material is 65 million
years old
I can't wait a few months I mean wait a
few years how lucrative is hunting for
fossils that depends upon how lucky you
are how skilled you are how much time
you have to dedicate to it and how much
money you have to invest in it in the
first place
although the commercial market is
thriving that doesn't mean it's easy to
make a living as a fossil hunter there
are many different hats so I'm a system
professor at Maple State University I
teach biology ecology that's the day job
if I have enough time to come out here
at the Badlands I switch hats you know
and become the Indiana Jones or the
Jurassic Park character this is one of
the best places on earth to find fossils
every year thousands of fossil hunters
flock here to the Badlands to try their
luck at finding buried treasure
recently one of the lucky ones was
Michael Gellin
who runs a small nonprofit fossil
hunting company to survey the land
Gellin worked out a deal with the
private landowner to split the sale one
day I was all walking and I
up into this box canyon in the distance
there was some white colored dinosaur
bone I realized wow this is a brow horn
that's how we found skull ax skull X
refers to the fossilized skull of an
adult Triceratops which gel and is
working to excavate but digging the
skull out of the ground is only the very
beginning of the process of getting the
specimen to market once the fossil is
secured in a dry jacket of plaster of
Paris Gellin will need to move the
approximately 500 pound mound of dirt
and rock across this ravine and then up
and out of this Canyon for gel and
digging up fossils of the labor of love
he knows that he will likely only
break-even on skull X but that doesn't
matter his primary interest is science
the reason why I decided to set fossil
excavators up as a nonprofit because I'm
not in it just for the money I've made
millions of dollars in the dinosaur
business you know I love capitalism
because the people that get to the top
of the hill get to do with what they
want to or their money welcome to my
studio where I clean and prepare fossils
I've sold thousands of fossils right now
I have a 30-year accumulation of
triceratops dinosaur bones and t-rex
dinosaur bones and head mana source
dinosaur bones and some new to science
bones I don't know what they are like
most commercial fossil hunters Tetrick
doesn't have a formal education in
paleontology but he knows his dinosaurs
what's more he's an accomplished artist
who can prepare and mount his own
specimens but perhaps most importantly
dietrich has a gift for sales wow this
is a 20-foot mosasaur from Kansas this
was 85 million years old give or take
three million years some people say 88
million
this is what you call the eyes of tiger
here this is what gets kids excited
[Music]
buyers you've got to excite their
imagination and what I like to tell
people is you know at some point you're
gonna be able to ride this thing off
into the sunset because your name will
live on that you owned this dinosaur
[Music]
today private ownership of fossils can
be seen as controversial but things
weren't always this way
commercial fossil hunting has existed
since the dawn of tailed modern
paleontology one of our most important
specimens in our own collection that's
on display here in the fourth floor is a
mummy of a duck-billed dinosaur that
specimen was commercially purchased from
a legendary fossil hunter named Charles
Sternberg so it's always been part of
the game
the modern commercial market took off in
1997 when sue the largest intact t-rex
skeleton ever found was auctioned off at
Christie's for 8.3 million dollars
everybody was just astounded that that
specimen would get that much money I
think before that nothing had ever been
sold above like $200,000 or so since
then the commercial market has boomed
driving up prices and making it harder
for public institutions like museums to
compete you know most people might feel
would go for more regulation I
personally would go for less regulation
because there's a lot more fossils out
there they're just being destroyed from
biting neglect in erosion then there are
paleontologists who can actually collect
them
after days of careful extraction and
plastering skull axe is finally ready to
move with a budget of a couple hundred
bucks how do you get out there you can't
go out and rent a helicopter what we do
have is a crew they have a lot of
creativity we're using these metal pipes
as a bridge kind of like railroad tracks
and then we're gonna slide across here I
[Music]
think the commercial market has a place
the financial side of it gives a
motivation for people to go out and look
for them it can serve them some of them
just are so remote they might not even
be found now the bad side of the market
is people can make up things and maybe
they'll make mistakes because they
weren't properly trained
well you got to be pragmatic as long as
these things are collected
you know ethically meaning that they're
not stolen off public land in this
country or they're not imported from a
country which it doesn't allow the
export of any fossils just get real with
it I mean just get used to it and this
is something that's gonna happen
[Music]
[Music]